all right everybody we've reached the
end of the hour but there's just enough
time for one more great story this is
what I'm
liking spring is just around the corner
and that means our national parks will
soon be filled with visitors I love
national parks a New Jersey teen wants
to inspire more people of color to visit
so she's written a children's book
called find your Forest that explores
the magic of The Great Outdoors because
it is very magical y'all we have her
dialed in say hello to 16-year-old
Audrey who watches on NBC New York hi
Audrey hi I so Audrey I'm with you I
love National Park so much I literally
feel like I live in one in Montana but
what inspired you to do this yeah so I
grew up in Brooklyn New York and living
in Brookland it really felt like forests
were some mystical far away place from
where I lived and when I got a little
bit older um we moved to New Jersey and
I was fortunate enough to live live very
close to a forest so I spent a lot of
time there and really just realized how
incredible it is to spend time in nature
it would calm me down and um allow me to
clear my head and so I started doing
some research on this and I discovered
something called the nature Gap um and
what this is is only about
10% of National Park visitors are people
of color and as a Latina myself this was
something that really shocked me so with
this book I wanted to inspire kids and
families from all backgrounds to get out
into the forests Earth is a it's amazing
it's magical and to be a part of it is
is amazing so who did you work with to
do this yeah so um I had the wonderful
opportunity to work with Forest
Educators at the US Forest Service um
along with a bilingual children's Media
company called enanos and the Ad Council
Who are the the folks that brought a
Smokey the Bear um and with them I
really wanted to make sure I was
accurately portraying the animals plants
and insects um that I was demonstrating
in the book and um not only did we want
this to be educational but also fun so
we have an activities list in the back
of the book and one of my personal
favorites is something called sound
mapping and sound mapping is when you
close your eyes and you listen to the
forest sounds around you and you draw
everything out on a piece of paper um
and with this book I really hope that I
can go out into my local forest or
forests around the country and see
families of all colors enjoying the
forest in message I do this is so cool
two different languages right here find
your Forest is on sale exclusively at
Target y'all be sure to get a copy thank
you so much Audrey I'm liking your post
right now right thank you and that's not
all ma' our season long partner pilot
pin makers of friction the go to
erasable pin at the Kelly Clarkson show
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like you ma'am so
they're going to give you $1,000 just
for being
rad thank you so much
Audrey thank you to all our guests this
our sir Rod Stewart Jules Holland Tamil
MZ Chef Scott and Melissa yall have a
great day if it's not
[Music]
changing
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home